when you look at the genomes of dogs a  lot of dogs you start to see a  surprising pattern domesticated dogs are  split into two groups Asian and European  the question is or all the dogs  descended from the same ancestor or were  dogs domesticated twice the answer is  complicated looking at the genes of  modern dogs the world over at first it  appears they all descended from worlds  some time before 14,000 years ago in  Asia and swept into the West between  14,000 and 6400 years ago but  archaeological evidence puts  domesticated dogs in Europe over 15,000  years ago that's about a thousand years  before this migration happened this  suggests that there was a separate  domestication event but the European  dogs largely disappeared when dogs moved  in from Asia there may be some fragments  of the Western domestication event of  modern dogs but every dog alive today  can trace most of its ancestry to Asia